oh did hans get the gm title did he win
wow he won in 22 moves let's see how
hans became a gm
how hans became a gm
so hans is playing white okay so playing
black
is gm
sebastian maze
or maybe it's maze and then playing
white
is i guess he's still
the last game of international master
han demon
i before e i before e
especially before man
okay so we already know the result i'm
going to hide the notation
so we know hans won and we know he won
in 22 moves
unfortunately like yeah there's or bound
to be some spoiler but we don't know how
so let's see the game i haven't seen it
uh
i had the tab open with a final position
but i try not to look at it
um so yeah how do you beat a gm in 22
moves
in like a slow game it happens but
this is probably the most important
games of of hanza's life
like the game to become a gm sadly i
can't really relate
okay so nimzo indian yeah i know hans
has been playing like a lot of
mainline d4
and he plays this is a so-called
rubenstein variation
i think it's the most common line
[Music]
if we just see the opening book oh queen
c2 is maybe slightly more common on
leech s
but e3 is most common in master level
play
so in this position as white
uh there's there's close to a dozen
playable moves
e3 queen c2 are probably most common
knight f3 g3 a3 bishop here
queen b3 is playable um
f3 is also a tricky line
so when you play the nimzo indian in
this black there's a lot that you have
to be prepared for
but okay he plays e3 solid approach
yeah you can't play e4 e4 is like the
one move
you can't really do because knight takes
e4 so yeah one one of the points when
black plays in nimzo
is to control the e4 square sometimes
with d5 sometimes with b6 bishop e7
so okay the game goes on castling
bishop d3 and b6 very typical
now 92 so i've played similar setups as
black before
okay so now a3 yeah usually
white plays a3 when when the knight's
supported by either the
other knight or the queen so in the
event of bishop take c3 the pawns don't
get doubled
uh here we see bishop e7 f takes takes
white would have the bishop pair and
[Music]
no double pawns okay so bishop e7
preserving the bishop here
and it looks a little bit passive
but i'd imagine yeah they're still in
some theory
oh now hans hans plays e4
interesting
also i should note in this position
black could take on g2
ohan said that b6 is a mistake really
wait wasn't there some having some vague
memory of like some
alpha zero game or lila game
was it this line though
so white stacking upon here takes takes
takes
this looks fun for white because you uh
you get the g file you get initiative
and then you play e4
this looks really fun e5 coming bishop
h6 queen comes in
g5 oh g5
like a g thanks tonic
maybe b6 is a small inaccuracy
it's been a while since i've looked at
these uh these variations
okay so we see e4
it seems like white just got a really
nice center
c5 d5 so now we have kind of a benoni
style structure
um yeah this is a typical structure
and black has less space usually these
sort of these sort of positions they
lead to really long
grinding games so i'm really curious how
hans won
so quickly knight g3
i guess white has a nice lead in
development too like maybe f4 at the
right moment
knife f5
yeah sometimes black wants to do like g6
knight g7 f5 but it's a bit slow here
g3 preparing f4 probably
or h4
man look at black's pieces black has a
single piece developed
and it's such a sad bishop too
also keep in mind lacks a grand master
but it's a great example like what to do
in the opening is white
like improve your pieces gain space
h4 can be useful in cases
usually for two reasons either to play
h5h6
or to eventually support bishop g5
okay so g6 maybe he was anticipating g6
and seeing the potential for h5 later
wow knight h6 king h8
king g2 i like this idea
from white's perspective i mean you have
so much time because black's really like
just stuck
but also uh the rook wants to be on the
h file
because after h5 the h file can open and
the king's just kind of
a very delicious looking
a sitting duck
so this uh yeah this king g2 facilitates
this
rook h1 h5 push so bishop g7
retreating the only developed piece but
maybe preparing f5
now we see h5 zohan's wasting no time
g5 and black probably just wants the
the position to stay closed now
knight g4 so threatening probably h6
would which would
be um really really nice looking
i'm curious why black didn't play h6
himself
not entirely sure maybe f4 would f4 will
actually looks really really strong here
just destroying the the pawns and h6
would be a weakness in the end
there's a line if we imagine like
everything takes
uh h6 is attacked king h7 would defend
but then walk into this
f5 we on passant with check so
just one example of how things can go
south for black
so queen d7 developing a second piece by
blocking the bishop
but threatening the knights so f3
defending the knight
now h6 yeah trying to keep things closed
[Music]
i like rook h1 it's the right moment you
might want to sack
and go for h6
i mean also the idea of f4 is
always lingering if you want to link to
the study
i'll link it in chat you can follow
along
so i think we're approaching the end of
the game what move are we on yeah we're
on move 20.
wait hans wanted two more moves
he wanted two more moves from this
position
i didn't look at the final moves but
let's try and
okay let's try and guess what he did
here
a6
did he go for bishop takes g5
is it winning
it's probably one of the first things
you calculate like bishop g5
pawn g5 h6 bishop has to move back
and you take and queen d2 rookie rook g8
it seems close
and some people in chat saying bishop g5
93 i mean 93 it's
um also logical like just to improve the
knight
knight a4 being suggested knight a4 is
kind of cool
he's going after the pawn trying to
spread black thin
actually knight a4 is really cool
i'm sure some people in chat like you
have the link to the study
you probably know the move i'm trying to
figure it out knight a4
because then when the queen moves then
we play f4
okay let's see oh some people okay some
people spoiling
93 that's surprising how does he win the
game in one more move
oh wow white's a move
twitch fetus
oh congratulations yes subbing for six
months
soon to be a baby thanks mlg alien
this is really cool like knight c7
in some senses of blunder
i mean the position was already kind of
difficult for black
but the the move here for white is um
it's incredible like i was expecting
white to just crash through on the king
side
but look at this move knight a4
black resigns
that's so awesome wow a game to become a
grand master
he built up this whole like impressive
kingside display
and knight a4 out of nowhere and the
point is black just doesn't have a good
way to defend the pawn
and when the pawn is lost
i mean i probably wouldn't have resigned
here i would play brook a7
like make him fight for it maybe he's
nervous but white wins b6
and white's gonna get rid of this bishop
plant tonight here play f4 it's so bad
for black
uh stockfish probably i would imagine
stockfish gives at least plus
2.5 plus four man
yeah because it sees
it sees like five moves ahead
oh it's actually saying okay we can take
the bishop
yeah playing that f5 and then
at the right moment play f4 what a game
i mean hans deserved it or deserves it
very deserving i mean he's worked really
hard
um he did have a tough loss
i think the game before this one was
like a super long game
he needed a draw to secure the title but
ended up losing
so um i might put this on youtube
dedicate it to hans
who he's also a twist streamer
he should start a youtube channel if he
doesn't have one already
so hi to youtube yeah reacting to hans's
uh hanza's achieving of the grand master
title
i know maybe i didn't cover all the
variations so thoroughly but
it was more just getting a sense of what
unfolded this game
it's cool to go through a game without
without knowing exactly what to expect
um i did learn like
there's some things to learn just from
seeing some of these moves
that you really have to take into
account the big picture and
identify the weaknesses don't have too
much tunnel vision
oh yeah hello to chicken nuggets at
least three chicken nuggets
also hi to pam so everyone in twitch
chat
say congratulations to hans
and again assuming this goes on youtube
i will link hans
uh twitch and other other links in the
video description
okay here is here's a congratulatory
twitch chat
twitch chat is so kind it's fabiano